hello today we are going to learn about
support vector machine or svm that is
another type of supervised machine
learning methods
many times it is not possible to have
any linear discrimination and finding a
quadratic function to delineate groups
is practically impossible which reduces
prediction accuracy
in those cases we can use another
important classification method that you
will see or use for your analysis of
rna-seq data
that is svm a support vector machine
it is an algorithm that differs from
other classification methods because it
is optimal to find a complex boundary of
a class in an efficient way to do so it
uses a procedure for feature space
transformation with a kernel function
for example a circular class border can
be achieved by a straight hyper plane if
the space was curved in such a way that
the classes are cut
with a decision surface
let's perform svm on cell line data
that we have already prepared to find
the svm function find the supervised
analysis section of the tbr info
platform
now upload the test and the train files
and build the pipeline
when you select svm you will see several
inputs that have to be specified
here you can select whether to scale
classes identify a cost parameter and
select a kernel type
linear polynomial radial or sigmoid
class scaling should be familiar to you
already from previous classification and
normalization methods it scales classes
to have the same distribution before
boundary is found cost parameter is the
penalty assigned to classification
accuracy for violation of the class
boundary kernel type is a measure of
complexity for separation between
classes if the class overlay is minimal
the fastest kernel should be used linear
svm output is all about prediction for
the test data set if the prediction is
accurate high accuracy will be
determined if the class separation has
not been accurate the cost parameter is
high low accuracy will be reported
changing the kernel type and reducing
features in the test entrained data set
will help improve accuracy in our case
optimal separation can be achieved after
feature selection this procedure is
possible using stepwise or greedy
approaches as well as a tree selection
by voting as we will learn about it in
the next section
to learn more about svm or support
vector machine you can visit lesson
number 14 under transcriptomics course
on the omixlogic.learnportal